we are now going to study the magical
republic of
fitlandia
and as we often do in economics we're
going to assume that fitlandia which of
course does not exist in the real world
is a very simple country it helps us
create a model for it let's say that
fitlandia is capable of producing two
goods it can either produce dumbbells
it's my best picture of a dumbbell right
over there or it can produce protein
bars so this right over here
that is a protein bar
or some combination of the two so we can
draw fetlandia's production
possibilities curve so let me write this
ppc production possibilities curve for
fitlandia sometimes this will be
referred to as a production possibility
frontier
and so let me draw two axes one for
dumbbells and one for protein bars
so the vertical axis right over there
and then
the horizontal axis right over here
and we're going to assume that
everything we do this is in
thousands
of
tons
per
year
and so in the vertical axis we have one
two
three
four
and five and the horizontal axis one
thousand tons per year two thousand tons
per year three thousand tons per year
four thousand tons per year and five
thousand tons per year and let's put
dumbbells in the vertical axis
dumbbells right over here
and let's put our protein bars in the
horizontal axis
and let's say we know that we're maybe
the economics minister for fitlandia or
the secretary of commerce or something
like that and we know that if we put all
of our energy into dumbbells and
optimally allocated our our resources we
could produce five actually let's say we
could produce four thousand
tons of dumbbells in a year
we also know that well if we wanted to
produce some protein bars we're going to
have to give up our production of some
dumbbells and so the more protein bars
we produce we're going to produce fewer
and fewer dumbbells and so we're going
to sit on this curve if we're producing
as efficiently as possible given the
resources we have and if we put all of
our resources into protein bars we could
produce 3000 tons of protein bars per
year
so this right over here is our
production possibilities curve if my
country is operating fully is operating
efficiently and all of the resources are
being used when i talk about resources
i'm talking about people's time so my
labor i'm talking about the factories
are being fully utilized the land the
material then i would sit someplace on
this production possibilities curve
sometimes it's referred to as a
productions possibility frontier because
you can't go beyond this unless
something changes we're going to talk in
a second about why they change so if you
sit on this curve
if you sit someplace on this curve and
the country might choose to sit at
different points on this curve
this is
efficient
efficient use
of the resources and it's kind of a
theoretical efficiency in in practice
almost no country can or really no
country can fully utilize all of its
resources where all of its people
are working absolutely all of the time
and so in reality a country might
actually sit a little bit below its
production possibilities could curve
so someplace behind it
now what would happen let's say a
country right over here and this is a
real let's say let's just take the
theoretical country that somehow is able
to operate super efficiently it's
sitting on its productions possibility
curve or its productions possibility
frontier and let's say it were to enter
into some type of a recession where all
of a sudden some of its population isn't
able to work so the labor pool isn't
being fully utilized what would happen
to its production
well its production would then go
well or would then go off the curve and
it would go to
down and to the left and so it might end
up right over here so here maybe we have
some
unemployment
unemployment
right over here and so this is an
inefficient use of resources
maybe fitlandia gets into a war with
some other country and that other
country destroys some of their
productive capabilities some of the
factories or maybe some of the people of
fitlandia decide to move someplace else
well then what would happen well then
your production possibilities frontier
would actually contract if you have
fewer factories or if you have a smaller
population or maybe you lose some
territory to another country then you
have fewer resources with which to
produce and so you could end up in a
scenario
where your production possibilities
frontier contracts to something
contracts to
maybe something like this and so this
movement of the production possibilities
curve this would happen if you have
contracting
contracting
resources
and likewise most countries of course
don't want to be in this situation most
countries want economic growth and
economic growth is when you have
expanding resources so how can we get
beyond this production possibilities
frontier maybe construct one that is
further out
let's say we want to get a production
possibilities frontier that looks
something
like this
and doesn't have to increase both of the
goods proportionately maybe we want to
get to a production possibilities
frontier that looks something like that
how could we get there well there's a
couple of mechanisms one is
you could have more capital
more capital what do we mean by capital
well maybe we invest in creating more
factories or getting more technology so
uh computer-aided things robots whatever
so that we could produce more
more either protein bars or dumbbells
per year another
possibility is we have more population
more especially working population
more
population
so the big takeaways here the production
possibilities curve or production
possibilities frontier for country are
the combinations of goods that it can
produce in a certain amount of time if
it's using all of its resources
completely efficiently if it gets into
some type of a recession or doesn't use
its resources efficiently then you're
going to have a production point some
kind of combination of producing goods
that sits under or behind your
production possibilities frontier maybe
there or there or there and maybe as you
come out of a recession you might get
again closer to your production
possibilities frontier
now there's also ways that you can shift
the entire frontier the entire frontier
or the production possibilities curve
can contract if you have contracting
resources factories that are bombed in a
war
net outward migration or your production
possibilities frontier can expand if you
have more population more people who
could be there to work to produce goods
more capital more factories more land
more material with which to produce
goods and so you can imagine most
countries want to do this and this
notion of expanding your production
possibilities frontier this is what we
refer to as economic
economic
growth